- Are those caffeine pills,
at first, they're so exciting.
And then it gets even more
exciting, but after that,
it gets so scary and in the end you ruin
your girl group shot at
a recording contract.
- What?
- Watching "Saved By The Bell" growing up,
I always thought it was
interesting that they never really
talk about Mario Lopez
or Slater being Mexican.
So as an Latino, watching this,
it was so refreshing to see the both
of you sort of take the
lead in "Saved By The Bell."
It was so, so cool, but
obviously, you guys play Daisy
and Aisha, low-income students, transfer
to Bayside high school,
school full of rich kids.
How did the both of you balance,
this really serious topic,
multiple series topics
with humor as well, Alicia,
why don't you start?
- It's an honor to be on this show
that has such notoriety all over the world
and has had such a special
place in people's hearts,
and then have us two Latinos spearhead it.
And I think one of the best
parts of our show is that we're
both from the same culture,
but our own distinct human
beings where these Latino women
with our own separate interests
and goals and passions.
And I think it really
touches upon the fact
that the Latinx community
is not a monolith,
and we have our own views and
we hope that we empower people
within our own community,
but as actors and performers,
it's been so fun, just
exploring the juxtaposition
between having these very
serious conversations that need
to be had, and really reflect
the world we live in today.
In addition to these
moments that are wacky
and unconventional, I think
it's one of the best parts
of our show, I think it disarms people
and hopefully shows people that no matter
where you come from or
where you look like,
these are things that you can
care about and conversations
about equity and representation
and diversity are things
that you should be
discussing in your household.
So it's awesome.
- Yes.
(all laughing)
(indistinct)
- Yeah girl
- I second that noise.
I seriously second that, I mean,
I grew up, not seeing a lot
of representation on TV
and I was always told
that I can do anything and be anything.
But I think as a young Latina,
it's always helpful in a way
to see someone that looks like
you, that speaks like you,
that has the same
background as you, because,
there's times where you may
get down on yourself because
that's a real thing, but to be able
to see someone being
represented in a certain light,
in a certain way, in a
certain form is so crucial
to someone's upbringing and mindset
and the way they take
information about themselves
and how they feel about themselves.
So I love the fact that you
not only have one Latino,
but you have two Latinas, and
two very different Latinas,
but also very similar in ways.
And, and I get to rock some, some curls
and you see, yeah, it's good.
They did a good job, I'm proud
of you, I'm proud of them.
- No, they really did.
Honestly, it was so dope
watching the both of you.
And I'm not just going to reiterate
everything you guys just said.
Lisa, you mentioned the
wacky and the unconventional.
That's what we loved about
Saved By The Bell a lot,
and this is stuff.
I remember watching a show
Saturday morning, eating cereal.
I'm like, this doesn't make any sense.
What was it like for the both of you?
Because we, what's cool is
that in this re-imagining
of the show, we, we still get
those wacky informational moments.
So what was it like for
the both of you to sort
of be the only rational
people at Bayside high school,
is Haskiri wanting you to take this one?
- I feel like I'm always rational
almost in my outside life
as, or hopefully I hope I am rational,
but being able to see that rationality,
I think plays very well
because then you really see
the difference between the
Douglas kids and the Bayside kids
and what separates them,
and how different they are
in their thought process.
And you kind of get to see that play off
on how each character kind
of rubs off on each other.
I get a lot of Lexi and a lot of Max kind
of way of doing things.
It's like not being able to
take charge and not being able
to enter a room and feel like
I'm taking up too much space
because that's how, what they do.
And I'm like, you know what,
I'm gonna do that same thing.
And then on the other side, I
feel like for their characters
is like, oh wow, Daisy is passionate
and she sees things differently
and she has a voice,
not only for herself, but
for everyone surrounding her.
Maybe I need to take a step
back and see that for myself
and kind of take that on as a
trait in, as a characteristic.
- We got to see that too,
because your character
breaks a fourth wall,
which I think is really
awesome that they can see
through Daisy's eyes
"Saved By The Bell" is one
of the best things, shows
to come out of the nineties.
I love the nineties and rocking Tommy,
what is your favorite nineties trend?
- I always say high
waisted jeans, high waist,
crops, crop tops, I
own a lot of crop tops.
I don't think I own a regular size t-shirt
(laughing)
I need to go shopping.
- That's actually a fact.
- Yeah, right everyday on set
that I did not have a crop.
- Anything like, but you look
phenomenal on your crop tops.
So keep wearing your crop top.
Specifically for me, I am in
love with the nineties culture,
but I think something really
cool about our new show
is that I, as Aisha wear
a lot of nineties fashion,
more reminiscent of the
nineties hip hop culture,
which we didn't really
see in the original "Saved
By The Bell," so you'll see,
Aisha wearing like really big,
similar to like TLC
overalls and door knockers.
So she definitely honors
the nineties in her fashion,
in this new cool, reinvented way.
(rap music)
- Can we talk?
- Did you just sit backwards in a chair?
Wow, I've never seen anyone
do that in real life.
- I am so stoked to talk to you guys.
My first question is
for you Belmont 'cause
you play Jesse's son, but you're sort
of like the Slater in this show.
So I was curious, you
got a chance to sit down
with Maria Lopez or Elizabeth
Berkley and talk to them
about your character and what
you wanted to bring in Jamie.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I remember, well, I met Elizabeth during
the audition process and
then when we were shooting
the pilot and that first week.
I had wrapped kind of
around the middle of the day
and Elizabeth was on
set just as a producer.
And we were sitting in video village
where there was everybody
watching the monitors,
and then it was somehow hours later.
We were just two people sitting in chairs
in this empty space, having
this wonderful conversation,
talking about how the
dynamic is, and the family,
and the relationship
between the two of them.
And yes, Jamie and Mario have
some similarities as well.
So I got, kinda got to dive
into those similarities with him
and just meeting both of
those original cast members
and working with them has
been an absolute blessing.
It is a very cool experience.
- What from Mario Slater,
did you wanna bring in
a Jamie specifically?
- Well, there's like this
competitive jockey sports aspect
to Slater that Jamie totally has.
The only difference is
Slater is genuinely athletic
and Jamie is clueless.
(laughing)
- And Dexter, you actually
got to shoot with Mario solo.
I got to see it a couple
of episodes, so tell me
what that was like, and do
you have any fun stories
from set shooting with him
specifically that you can share.
- Yeah of course, I
mean, when I got the role
and I found out that the
majority of my scenes were going
to be with him in the pilot,
it definitely just brought me
in a little ounce of
nervousness, if I'm being
a hundred percent transparent with you,
but excitement as well.
And then of course, meeting
Mario and chatting with him
and he gives you that
smile and then brings you
in for that handshake and hug.
It makes everything go much
more easy and it allows you
the opportunity and the space
to be able to create something
really, really beautiful and special.
- Mario and I have so many
mutual interests, from dance,
from being pop culture
nerds of the eighties
and the nineties.
And so, we were always
dancing around on the set
in trailers and shooting Instagram videos.
And his daughter is very big on TickTock.
And so whenever, she was
around, we would be making
them some TickTok dances
and stuff like that.
So Mario and Elizabeth, both,
actually all, every single OG
that we brought back really
made it a point to just sow
into us and allowed us know that,
hey, we know we were the
first, but you guys are the now
and we appreciate you and we support you.
And so having that really
was, was really fantastic.
- That's a really nice sentiment,
especially because your character Devante,
I hope I'm saying it right,
because it was funny how
you pronounced my name in the show.
Whoever's watching this
and you watched the show
that'll make sense, but I
wanted to ask the both of you,
is there any, did you go back and watch,
the original and it's kind
of fun to poke fun at sort
of the corniness and that
she missed from that show.
So what was easy for
you guys to naturally,
poke fun at this time
around from the original.
- It is fun Tracy Wakefield,
our show runner did such
a phenomenal job of toeing
that line between being
self-aware about the corniness
of the original show,
and then still honoring
the beautiful aspects of the
original that everybody loves.
Really just walking that tightrope,
Tracy did a phenomenal job.
And so it was very fun, but
humor is a little different,
just like the show is
different because it's newer,
but I'm excited about all the jokes.
Yeah, growing up, such a big
fan of the original show,
like I love Zach, Kelly,
Screech, Slater, Lisa, Jesse,
like I loved them growing up,
but I do also understand
that "Saved By The Bell"
in the nineties is not
work, does not work in 2020.
So I think like, like
Belmont said so beautifully,
Tracy and our producer
Franco, who was a part
of the original series, found
a really, really great way
to combine the nuance
and the nostalgic aspect
of the original show with the
groundedness and the reality
of the world that we live in today.
And I hope that it
continues to be transformed,
like translated that way
and understood that way.
- What is your favorite thing
to come out of the nineties?
Favorite nineties trends.
- Oooh, the Jordan one, the Jordan one,
the hot top Jordan one.
It could be the OG, all the
different color already.
All iterations, I'm a sneaker
head, I love sneakers.
And so then now my accent just
made like am a sneaker head.
- Yeah the accent.
(laughs)
- I immediately get right back
to my South Jersey cities,
but yeah, the Jordan ones
is probably the best thing
to come out of the nineties for myself.
- For me, it's gotta be the
music, I love all, I still,
most of the music I listened
to it comes from the nineties.
REM, Weezer, the police,
all that good stuff,
but yeah, I'm a sneaker head too.
(laughing)
- And do you only know how
Bayside works for kids?
- Hot kids?
- Privileged kids.
- Oh my God, Lexi, your
character is just everything.
Serving books, best one
liner, she's transgender.
We so rarely get that
type of representation
in the TV space, let alone
the high school TV space.
So first wanted to ask
you, what was it like
and how did you feel bringing,
being able to bring Lexi
to life with that in mind?
- I mean, she is literally
the most fun character
I've probably ever played,
getting to wear six inch heels
to algebra two in the morning.
It was an experience I never
thought I would live through.
She is so fun and there's
so much to her that I think
is so interesting and
entertaining to watch throughout
her experience on the show
and her arc as a human being.
I think you see evolve
throughout the season.
And I think that's really
topical for so many people
in America right now, having
this kind of reckoning,
where they're realizing
their privileged bubble
isn't everything.
And I really love that about her
and the other Bayside
kids are in the show.
- What did it mean to you to
be able to bring a transgender
character to life in sort of this space?
Because we so rarely
get that representation.
- Yeah it meant everything to me.
I think when Tracy came
to me about wanting
to do the show, it
wasn't originally planned
for her to be transgender, but
the more we talked about it,
the more we saw an opportunity
to have representation like
this onscreen, because so
often trans representation,
as we know, usually has to
do with the trans struggle
or puts trans people in a negative light,
in a negative experience.
So getting to tell a story and
serve as a producer on a show
where I had input on making
sure it was authentic
as possible was the
greatest opportunity ever,
because I think with me
and Tracy coming together
and our writers, we really
told a story that isn't all
about her gender, and it's so much more
than just her gender, but
does tackle that part of her,
which I think is really, really important.
- So incredible and so needed.
And can't wait to see so
many more, and you kill it
and saw your also, producer on the show.
So congratulations for that, it's amazing.
- [Josie] Thank you
Obviously, you know,
Lexi's this, she's awesome.
She's this cheerleader, most popular girl,
popular girl in school.
We've seen this archetype before,
so who are your main influences for Lexi?
Like did you go back and watch
like Regina George clips?
Like who was your main influence?
- My biggest influence
for Lexi was the dreams
that I had growing up as a young child.
Only wishing I could dress, talk, act half
the way Lexi does.
So that was my full on sort
of, I would say inspiration
for the character, but the more I did it,
the more I found myself talking a lot
like Catherine O'Hara in "Schitt's Creek."
I've literally said
this in every interview,
I guess what I'm saying
here is I'm obsessed
with Catherine O'Hara
and "Schitt's Creek."
I wish I was her, and
I'm sad that I'm not.
But I just found myself like,
speaking in weird dialects
in the same vein that Catherine
does in that wonderful show.
So yeah, I'd say a mixture
of her and of just my dreams.
- That's, honestly iconic
Moira Rose is literally
my favorite character and
I'm happy you said that
because I wanted to ask where
you got Lexi's mannerisms
and just the way she moves her hands.
I wasn't sure if it was
just how you are or,
but yeah, watching Schitt's
Creek, like I notice you sort
of whisper your last line,
when you're saying things
like you'll sort of lower your voice.
So I wanted to know
where all that came from.
Did that come from why you Maira Rose?
- Yeah, I mean, there were
certain things that came
from her, but honestly just
me and my regular life.
People that know me know that
I'm an insane human being.
Like I have moments where
I can be a humble child
that speaks normally, but I
also have moments where I am in,
person from Mars and I'm
not making any sense.
But what I thought was
actually funny is throughout
the show, I like wanted to
find new ways of holding
like my little handbags.
And I saw that the girl who played Alexis
on "Schitt's Creek" like
had the same sort of idea
of like finding new ways to do it.
So she did like the pretend handbag thing.
And my thing was holding a
handbag with just one finger.
And you'll see, I believe it's
in episode seven where I have
this tiny purse that
is literally big enough
for an edamame AP.
And like, that's it maybe
like half of a lip gloss tool.
And throughout the
entire episode, I hold it
with a single finger, so
that'll be fun for people.
- Say, that is so amazing,
now it's like my dream answer,
because I've done a lot of
research on how Alexis took
this and made it this.
So I just want to ask
you one last question.
What is the best thing to come
out of the nineties for you?
- The best thing to come
out of the nineties for me
is probably the fashion,
the low rise Jean moment,
the messy, dirty girl hair
moment and the spice lip.
I think we need to bring it back.
She deserves to be researched,
so those things, I would say.
- My dad's also coming.
- I don't care about your dad's Spencer.
I just care about Zach and Kelly's
- hello, John, should I
call you John or Michael?
I don't, I feel like you
go by Michael, right?
- I do go by Michael, most
people don't know that,
but yeah, if you wanna get my, if I safe
is about to fall on my head, say Michael,
because I'll move on.
If you call me John I have
to think for a minute,
I was like, Oh, I'm John.
So.
(laughs)
- Michael, there's a
thief coming, amazing.
- Aaargh!
(laughs)
I have waited a very long
time to interview you.
Your career is just so varied.
You've played so many
different characters.
What was it like coming into
the role of principal Todman
and playing a high school principal?
- It's not the first high school
principal I've ever played.
I think I've played about 94 of them.
(laughs)
And it's one of the things I
do a lot, anything that works
with a tie, that's what I do.
(Naz laughs)
But I actually love this show.
I've really, I've become
very attached to this show.
And I think part of it is that
my colleagues are so young
and talented, and I sort of
am reminded of when I was
a young actor and how
I engaged with the work
and how I was changed by
it and things like that.
And I've been doing it so
long now that you do forget
these things and they're very important,
And I have just been sort
of enlivened by this job.
Strange, I really have,
cause I'm one of the only,
like there's just a
few adults in the cast,
and it's really thrilling to work
with that much collegians frankly.
- Right, collegians.
(both laughing)
Michael you are hilarious.
Yeah, no, to being around someone,
that seeing something for the
first time is very exciting.
- It is.
- And to hear you say
that it livened it up,
it sort of warms my heart
to hear you say that,
that's really cool.
You've played so many principles
that obviously this is a
reboot, so did you
channel Mr. Belding at all
or reference his performance for Todman?
- Well, yeah, we like to say that the show
is a re-imagining, not so much a reboot
because there are so many new characters.
Really, Mario's character and
Elizabeth Berkley's character
are the only characters
that are in the regular cast
that are returning from the
old show, from the nineties.
I'm a totally different person
than Dennis Haskins played.
I have a different name, I have
a different set of problems,
I have a different personal life.
So I don't really do, I didn't
need to do research there.
What was useful for me
is to watch a couple
of the old episodes and watch
out Dennis Haskins negotiates
his performance amongst the
kids, because it's tricky.
The sweet spot of the show
was watching these kids,
the group and friends, and
see what issues they have.
And then this sort of referee,
this adult referee is walking
around mostly to be pranked
and to being demeaned
in some way, 'cause he's
the heavy, but also to sort
of facilitate what they're doing and sort
of pull comedy out of them.
So that was very useful
to watch Dennis do that.
And he's super good.
- At the same time
there's also a lot of you
in this character, I know you've
come from Broadway Michael
you've written vocal
arrangements for things
you've been in, I don't
wanna give too much away,
but obviously principal Todman
does have like a musical tie
in the show, people will
see once they watch it.
So how did that come about?
Was that your idea?
- Well, I think, Tracy Wakefield,
who's our creator on
this show and our writer,
she and I have a relationship.
She and I did a show together
called great "Great News"
on NBC a couple of years ago.
And, so she, once she
gets to know a person,
me in particular, in this
case, she can write toward me,
and so a lot, she knows that
I'm musical and she knows
that I do X well or Y well,
and she will go ahead and write
it in, because she likes to see me do it.
And she also unfortunately
knows what hurts for me.
So she will make, she will demean me.
I'm very often in the writing,
me personally, Michael,
so that, she knows that I
will be embarrassed by some
of the things that I have to say.
(laughs)
She knows how to get me.
So it's really, it's been a pleasure.
- I am shocked to even hear you say
that you've been embarrassed
because just some of the stuff
that you've done is so,
I after one Martini,
I turn into Richard from the breakup.
Oooh, how many times have you
been asked to do in real life?
- Oh my gosh, boy, you hit
it on the nose, I tell yah.
Naz, I can't go into a grocery
store without somebody,
pointing across the, the
coffee aisle and saying like,
there's Gary on the "Kick drum"
there, you know what I mean?
It's happens all the time,
it's every day, almost, yeah.
Just that one scene, you never know,
you never know you do a scene,
I didn't even remember it.
And years later it's like, I
have to deal with it every day.
It's crazy.
(upbeat music)